you guys see me alright everything's
good cool well happy end of the
conference thank you for joining me in
the last session and hope you guys ready
to do some some Kotlin work for all you
see sharp devs and enjoy my corny just
half-hearted Photoshop of super smash
bros melee versus sign really though
we're not gonna be doing like a column
verse C sharp we're gonna just be sort
of comparing the languages and allowing
you to basically take your tools from C
sharp and your knowledge of C sharp and
in writing applications in that style
and apply it to Colin so real quick for
those who don't know me I'm Alex done
you'll find me online as suave pirate
that's because my name is super super
basic when I was trying to basically
start actually building my online
personality I was like oh let's see what
kind of Alex Dunn's there are turns out
there's three Alex Dunn developers at
Microsoft so I didn't really have a good
place to sit so I wrote a little name
generator' took a bunch of stuff from
the dictionary just adjectives and and
noun and Here I am a suave pirate and I
couldn't even get the the full Twitter
handle so my blog is Alex dun org or
suave pirate calm this whole series is
is also a blog series on Alex Nunn org
and it's also shown in a bit of content
in Pluralsight so I'm sorry I'm a
Microsoft MEP in the.net space and Azure
space and also a Pluralsight author
where my course is focused in Kotlin and
specifically Kotlin and android so I
have getting started courses if you do
like the plural site scale IQ exams for
Android or for Kotlin that's a lot of my
questions and I'm sorry if they're hard
or super easy but you can kind of see
like that that's sort of weird balance
and turmoil I have internally has led to
a super interesting talk like this I
don't know if I can follow up very well
from the last talk which is like
building tanks and unity and blowing
up but we can compare languages and
I'll be pretty cool
so to preface like I said I don't want
this to be a let's ditch c-sharp and go
to Colin Cowan so sick and I also don't
want it to be like ha look I showed you
guys Colin and this thing actually sucks
we should stay with c-sharp and said I
think both really have a place and I
think that they're they come across is
so similar that it makes sense to take
your knowledge from either
and apply it towards developing
something in the other if you have that
need and we'll get into basically some
code comparing contrasting looking into
syntax for Kotlin versus c-sharp for
some of the basics and then get a little
more complicated and then also talk
about like there's use cases in terms of
like what platforms they best fit and
when you should use each one and lastly
we're specifically talking about Kotlin
1.3 I just updated this talk to do 1.3
and also some c-sharp 8 both of those
releases between c-sharp 8 and Collin
1.3 were like massive releases so column
1.3 we get things like better
asynchronous programming with
co-routines
and c-sharp a diffuse on e of like Mads
talked CERN or John ski talking about
some of the new features it's ridiculous
like Nobel reference types default
interface implementations asynchronous
streams and we'll talk about all of
those and also compare those new
features and how even still there
they're continuing to sort of lift each
other in terms of like features that the
language can complete so I'll just do a
quick overview of Collin how many you
guys actually know what Collin is and
you walked in here knowing you're gonna
learn a new programming language and not
like a framework alright how many you
guys had no idea what Collin is and
you're like oh another thing for c-sharp
developers and yeah sorry we're going to
talk about an entirely new programming
language that has nothing to do with
c-sharp other than that they're really
similar so the brief overview of Collin
it's an open source statically typed
language and it's written by JetBrains
one of the the gracious sponsors of this
conference its supports mostly in a sort
of targeted towards mostly an
object-oriented style programming but
there is a lot of support for functional
programming in Kotlin we'll talk a
little bit about that but not that much
since again this is like a c-sharp for
Kotlin it runs on the Java Virtual
Machine that's not just like I can
execute like a Kotlin like decks or
custom decks or something it's a hundred
percent interoperable with Java which
means you can write things in a modern
language throw Java behind where it
belongs and actually use usable code but
still like retrofitted in the Java and
then the other way around take existing
Java libraries use them in your
Coughlin's code the way you'd sort of
expect and I think this last line is the
most surprising race we talked about it
runs on the JVM you can actually
compiling to JavaScript and that's like
officially supported compiler we won't
get into too much depth about how that
works I have it like a totally different
talking series on that but basically you
can take like typescript types run it
through a tool that they have and
generate Kotlin types and then compile
your own Kotlin into JavaScript and then
just load it all up as one like minified
file so it's pretty cool the primary
goals of Colin as a language I think are
really important because you'll notice
as we go through the code that every
single bit of code we we look at keeps
all of these things in mind so number
one is reduced verbosity coming from
like the Java world which is you know
Kotlin sort of routes Java is super
verbose I hate Java personally like it
sort of stemmed into c-sharp development
sort of code style that was very
intentional from like C sharps like J
plus plus and now we actually have a
real programming language but also to
support many different styles of
programming so like I said there's
object-oriented there's everything every
tool you need for that will dig into
that but also functional you can write
things procedural you can script with it
in sort of everything in between and
then from the beginning having backwards
compatibility it's super important for
being able to execute Colin in older
Java code so even though we're sort of
introducing like modern language
features we still need to be able to
find some way to make that usable in our
ugly Java and then of course a faster
development cycle like I said this comes
from JetBrains and their entire team
everything they do is about making our
lives easier with building code faster
and building our applications faster so
you'll see that in sort of like the
ability to do like multi-platform
deployments with Colin just how easy it
is to quickly spin up Colin and just how
integrated it is into the different IDs
so in psychology there's a sort of
concept called speech convergence and
it's essentially when someone is thrown
into a room with a bunch of people who
either speak a different language or
speak with an accent they start to sort
of fall into that bucket as well I
personally have it so badly where like
if any of you come and talk to me
afterwards I'm like fighting internally
not to like speak with a bad British
accent and it will slip sometimes and so
I apologize I'm not mocking you it's my
brain is just wired in in the worst way
but this this concept also comes through
a lot
with new programming languages you can
tell what's inspiring a language based
on its structure its platforms in its
use cases and Kotlin themselves
explicitly say on their website that
it's inspired by existing languages like
Java obviously if they just want to get
rid of Java good call
c-sharp which is why I get to talk like
this JavaScript because it can run in
JavaScript and in Scala and groovy
there's sort of more functional and
procedural languages so any questions
about like Kotlin at all what I'm going
to do next is get into like some of the
very basics side by sides between like a
c-sharp example and a Kotlin example and
this I'm gonna break this down so you
guys can just ask questions the whole
way like feel free to interrupt me cool
so let's let's start with a poco you
know plain old CLR object POJO if you're
in Java and what I've seen toss around
sometimes with a poco with a k4 Kotlin
so I'm very much into dogs and
especially rescuing dogs so all my
examples are going to be related to that
so just don't be surprised with how many
times you see dog or a service that
relates to a dog or something like that
so here we have a c-sharp 7 version of a
poco for dog has a name an age just an
integer and a breed it's as simple as we
can get it right so in the cotton world
we have the exact same sort of structure
and I'm going to start by pointing out
some of the differences here right so
you'll notice right away everything is
explicitly nullable or not knowable
reference types value types or whatever
that is super similar to the the c-sharp
8 version of knowable reference types
with that optional field you can turn on
now and we'll talk more about that in a
bit
but you also notice that we have to
explicitly set a value for these
properties
whereas in c-sharp we get that sort of
default concept and we can even call
default in terms of assigning of value
so for string name and the c-sharp side
that's just going to be null by default
it will be 0 breed will be null as well
but in the Colin side all three of these
are knowable we have to explicitly set
it to null or to a value and then we can
take a look at some constructor override
so in a basic boko we don't have to
define our default constructor right it
sits there we have our empty parameters
constructor but if we want to add one
that adds the ability to set the name
age and breed
directly from the constructor we have to
now add the default and then add any
overrides same thing in Kotlin except
you'll notice the syntax is a bit
different and one thing you might have
noticed right away is that up here in
the signature is where we actually
define our default constructor so the
sort of thing in that that my instead of
reducing verbosity let's just throw it
up there so then we override
constructors with just adding that sort
of constructor keyword whatever
parameters and then whatever logic we
need to do collin also introduced this
concept of a data class it's kind of
similar to using a struct instead of a
class in c-sharp it actually does a bit
more so this one-liner at the top is
actually the entire class definition
with a constructor that takes in those
values but instead of saying like if I
go back to the previous slide just named
as the string ages and int or whatever
we actually say Val name is a string Val
ages and an invalid is a string and that
actually gives us those public
accessible properties with those names
as well as the constructor to set them
it's one line no braces you can do that
with any other class but I specifically
want to talk about the data class
because you can instantiate it like this
you get default copies for helping with
immutability you get the equality
comparisons you get like hash code sets
and stuff like that too I'll just built
in by just you know slapping a data on
it there's also this concept of vowel
and var in in terms of relating that you
can think of var as a variable and Val
is a value so a variable can change its
value a value can not it's set once and
that's it
if you relate that to c-sharp that beam
like a constant in a property or a
read-only because you can set them in
the constructor and you're good to go
the difference though is actually in
this this function here where Vallon var
is actually true for any statement of a
value or a variable regardless of scope
so here we're not defining properties of
the function bark we're just saying like
a local variable and we cannot set the
new value of sound because it's a value
we also have that same sort of concept
of getters and setters if you've ever
come from the Java world this isn't a
thing you have to explicitly have like a
get property name and a set property
name and that's sort of how you handle
encapsulation again the idea of saying
throw away all this extra methods and
functions we have
- right let's just use our getters and
setters c-sharp has done this you know
from years ago but we have the ability
to call a single get on the sage and it
does a calculation and you can just call
dot age in column we have almost the
exact same thing we can define get as a
function and it returns a whole bunch of
calculations except we have to do more
because we're using Java State and it's
garbage compared to c-sharp date time
but everything else is sort of the same
you have the same sort of like initial
sets on the right and all that and if
you're doing a a set method same thing
to show the next line set whatever you
need to do when defining methods and
functions in c-sharp we have the ability
to have a void method it doesn't return
anything just execute some code and we
can also have return types for methods
right in Kotlin it's the exact same
concept everything's just prefixed with
function that's how we're telling it
that this is a function or a method and
then the return type just like
everything else was over here on the
right side after that it's you know it's
just like executing any other method we
can just call dog adoption service that
adopt one thing you'll also notice is
that we don't have to use the new
keyword if we take the class name and we
throw the parentheses around it that's
over instantiating it just taking little
shortcuts to to cut up some of the extra
characters we get a type my favorite
thing in c-sharp that I abuse the hell
out of especially when writing new
c-sharp eight is null coalescing and
propagation so in this case we have both
examples in one we have this breed class
it has a knowable integer and then in
the dog class we have that breed which
is a reference type so it's default
nullable and then we also have the
ability to get that with the color
propagation rather and the coalescing so
propagation you see if I can get this to
work there we go
propagation being that if breed is null
this whole statement is evaluated to
null we're coalescing is saying if the
left side is null then return the right
side if not just return the actual value
of the left side and if we want to do
that we're saying hey I actually know
that this isn't going to be no L don't
worry about it
we can just do it dangerously and in
risk that no reference exception and
then also called dot value on those
knowable types that does change a bit
and c-sharp eight where start there on
the bangs or exclamation points whatever
you want to call it around Kotlin is has
both of those as well as just a slight
syntax
difference where we still get the
propagation with the question mark in
the dot but with coalescing we get the
question mark and the colon and then if
we're going to do something dangerously
we have to explicitly put the double
bang it's also just a good tell like I'm
probably messing something up here if I
have to do this especially because
everything's knowable or not knowable so
if I'm saying I guarantee you this
knowable type is not null I better know
what I'm doing and I can see that I can
with tons of exclamation points
everywhere so questions on the basic
syntax of that and then we'll take a
break from the sort of side by side code
examples and we'll talk about the the
platforms that both of these support
yeah I'll get into that I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the encapsulation but
the default for Kotlin is actually
public so if you want it to be
non-public then you got to throw a
private or protected or internal on it
yeah I know other questions yeah sorry
it does yeah so other than functions
it's unlike like a JavaScript object
function it's those two are separate but
you can still actually execute that so
everything comes from object yeah and
you'll actually see a really cool
indicator they have four that when we
talk about statics anything else cool
all right let's talk about some
platforms so these these are more or
less my opinions we we as c-sharp
developers know that c-sharp can run
just about everywhere but we sort of
have like these buckets of what most
people are using C sharp for based off
even just like Stack Overflow surveys so
obviously asp.net ASP it on that core
we're writing web applications we're
running things on is running things in
containers we're using asp.net you also
have cloud apps and that's sort of just
like a generalization of where we're
running our c-sharp code so i could be
running like a function lambda in terms
of laser functions a Tobias lambda or
just any sort of cloud execution or
services you also have the entire
Windows platform so think like think you
WP WPF WinForms and I I like to consider
xamarin one of the newer primary
platforms I myself abused Dameron a lot
sort of how I I came into the Microsoft
every piece of
always through xamarin and so we can
build cross-platform mobile apps on that
platform to which which runs on mono
collins core has spring and k tour so
this is think of this is their asp.net
right spring is Java's MVC framework so
it allows us to write java code that
runs in the JVM and can take in requests
and do everything in between and the
continent seemed actually introduced in
and runs this open-source project called
K tour which I still don't know if I'm
saying right at first just supposed to
be called Couture but I'm gonna keep
going with K tour so it's mostly like a
even nicer version of spring MVC it runs
more similarly to like in asp.net MVC or
node with Express where you're defining
endpoints and routes and you're just
running your code from there and you can
handle all your abstraction layer and
all that you also have the same thing
with cloud apps I think this is actually
a more popular language to use for cloud
apps simply because of the JVM
so obviously Amazon if you don't know
does a lot in Java so a lot of things on
AWS start with their Java SDK first then
their JavaScript SDK and then someone
finally supports a c-sharp developers
and then Android which I think it was
about two years ago that Google
officially announced Kotlin as a
supported language for Android
development so outside of just saying
like oh yeah you can write count line
and compile it with your java stuff and
now you've got android they're tooling
with Android studio is actually pretty
incredible so you can do things like
take existing Java code like an entire
file just like right click convert to
Kotlin and it's done so nice or the
other side like taking an existing Java
snippet copy and paste it into a column
file and it'll go hey I think that was
Java
you probably wanna switch this to Kotlin
cuz you're a smart person do you want to
do that yes and it dumps it in for you
automatically translated it's like
really well done - it's not like
translated as a bunch of build errors
because they're interoperable there's
like oh yeah we know like static is
companion and these objects go to this
and get rid of the get sets and stuff
like that in terms of other platforms
the c-sharp covers a whole lot right so
we have new IOT services even more
coming out with things like metal labs
new new microcontroller and stuff like
that we have unity which if you're in
the room here before we got to saw a
great demo of stuff blowing up in unity
we have mana which like I said is also
the foundation of xamarin but is also
used to run things on any sort of NYX
kernel and then uno a newer
cross-platform mobile and then blazer
which if you didn't have a chance to see
those all the different blazer talks at
this conference I definitely recommend
finding the videos later because blazer
is pretty sick countless other platforms
include iOS actually and this is sort of
like a secondary platform where people
are like hey we can now compile the
native let's see if we can like
translate things from iOS to Kotlin so
like if you go to Collin conference
their iOS after an entirely uncommon
which is pretty cool
JavaScript like I said compiling down a
JavaScript that's still in beta native
with LLVM that compiler to native is
also in beta but they're working on
releasing that in production and then
anything on the JVM which Java always
boasts we have a hundred billion devices
that run Java or three hundred billion
devices now whatever it is anywhere
you're doing that you can also use
Kotlin instead now like I said let's
just please get rid of get rid of Java
so I sort of have this Venn diagram
where on the left was c-sharp we have
the Windows platform right that's what
we can build for in a very native way
that we can't really do with Collin and
then Kotlin everywhere that the JVM is
running I don't think I'd ever dare
trying to compile C sharp to to the JVM
but like literally everything else both
of these platforms can or both these
languages can support in one way or
another colin is still very immature
it's only an aversion 11.3 so where C
sharp is moving into eight and it's been
around for so many years Colin still
sort of in infancy but I expect as this
community grows around just the love for
the language itself we'll also see more
the platform support as well any
questions about that before I get more
Cody cool I should expected more
questions for that because people are
like but what about this framework in
this platform all right let's talk about
object-oriented programming so those you
have written C sharp and I hope most of
you here are because that's kind of the
talk object oriented programming is sort
of the foundation of of our design
patterns and stuff C sharps introduce
some features to make it a little easier
to not do object
programming which some people hate some
people don't but let's start with the
foundation right we have a class that
defines an object and we start with our
object and we need to make sure that
Kotlin can help us fill out the other
pillars of object-oriented programming
now whether you want to debate if it's
this for abstraction encapsulation
polymorphism or inheritance or if you
don't like the idea of inheritance being
its own because polymorphism can
arguably handle that or if you've got
like the full six I'm talking about
these four and in my opinion the things
that we need to have in order to support
these are encapsulation keywords public
private protected all that inheritance
is obvious to be able to inherit classes
abstraction and polymorphism can also be
helped with the way that we can handle
multi-level inheritance or interfaces
and abstract classes and sort of
everything in between so let's start
with interfaces which is my favorite
recently debated for some reason thing
in c-sharp where people are like yeah
interfaces or abuse and di is too much
I say no I love di so we have an AI
adoption service right and we have two
methods to find there we have a void
adopt dog and avoid adopt dogs that
takes in a list and we have our
implementation of that which is dog
adoption service which influenced I
adoption service and does some super
basic stuff we can loop over and call
the other adopt dog in Kotlin we do get
our default interface implementations so
something that's new and c-sharp eight
is being able to do that but I'm also
using the actual like Java naming
convention so an interface is the dog
adoption service and the class is the
dog adoption service implementation I
hate this naming convention I like the I
better it's shorter it's it's easier to
read where I'm like dog adoption service
is that a class or the interface I have
no idea because if it's a class it
doesn't implement an interface and it
doesn't start with our end in freaking
imple sorry anyway we have this adopt
dogs which goes around each of the dogs
passing in and calls adopt dog and then
here all we have to do is implement the
one method encapsulation we talked about
this a little bit where everything is
sort of default public in Colin where
that's not true for c-sharp so we have
some common keywords like public for
classes and then Fred
members of that class we can also
encapsulate it with certain keywords
like public protected private or default
which is like basically private with
like some other extra gunk and then
within that we can also nest classes
right in Kotlin we have all of the same
ones but there's also a little bit more
one thing you'll notice right away is
they all assume we've got this open
keyword in front of our class because
just like everything is default public
it's also default final which if you're
not familiar of from the Java world
that's essentially saying that it's
default public sealed class in c-sharp
so in order to say that something can
inherit from dog we throw the open
keyword and then if you for whatever
reason need to explicitly say that it's
not inheritable you can throw a final up
there as well
same thing with public is it is a
keyword you can use but it's default so
no one really does that so you can keep
everything on the left side like on the
line so then we have our default public
and final variable that can change name
our private variable of breed are
protected which is similar to C sharps
protected but I believe it can actually
be accessed within the entire same
package which is essentially a folder
and then we have private for those sort
of subclasses as well we have a whole
bunch of other key words we can use
though c-sharp we can use sealed which
is like I said is sort of similar to the
default for Kotlin we have virtual which
explicitly says this can be overridden
for a method or property we have
internal which means that only my final
package only my final dll can access
this nothing else and we have our
default and it called let me have final
like I mentioned that's that's making
sure that it's the same as sealed but
can also be applied to local variables
so that's like Val is the same as a
final whatever type in Java then we have
open means it can be inherited internal
like I mentioned and then external which
I personally haven't found a use case
for but it's basically like only people
outside this can access it I don't know
why you'd really do that but you can all
right let's carry on so we have abstract
classes this example isn't the greatest
because it's basically like an interface
with the default implementation but
an abstract class we can add the keyword
abstract and then within that abstract
to any of our given members so that
means that any implementer or inheritor
sorry of that abstract class needs to
implement that abstract member right so
that's like having an interface where we
have a default adopt dogs so the biggest
difference is if you haven't used
abstract classes is that you can also
use things like protected and stuff like
that if it's abstract it doesn't have to
default public so and you can also only
inherit one thing and that's also true
for Kotlin where we have our abstract
keyword that's so it's an abstract final
public class an abstract public function
adopt pet and then the loop that sort of
runs over it which is then implemented
to call the abstract method and our
implement or sorry our inherit our child
class of adoption service being dog
adoption service has to override that
adopt pet now for the not-so
object-oriented things that people
usually try to avoid side of it the
concept of statics and stuff like that
right so to make something static and
c-sharp we just throw static keywords in
front of it and now it can be accessed
in a static way we can just say adoption
helper dot a dot pet and we're good to
go
but in Kotlin they actually is a naming
convention that I didn't I didn't expect
so there is no static keyword in Kotlin
which really threw me off when I was
like first learning and I was like how
do I make like an extension method and
make it static and like that and you
don't do that so it actually has the
concept of an object you think about it
makes sense right a static class is an
object that's initialized when the
program's run initially and so instead
of saying a static class we just have an
object and then we define whatever
members of that object we want and those
are all brought up statically throughout
the application so the same thing in
terms of how do we actually use this
adoption helper it's still just adoption
helper dot a dot pet so on top of static
objects we also have the the concept of
static members normally this is like
alright yeah I get it we throw static
around in c-sharp but I wanted to show
this to show you this the the real
difference in Kotlin so in this case we
have a public non-static class of
adoption service and we have
have the instance method of adopt and
also a static one that takes on that pet
as well and the implements are the use
of it or saturation of is we have to
instantiate adoption service first it's
not for calling static right that makes
sense so everyone knows how to do that
in Kotlin like I said there is no static
keyword
so we have our instance adopt we have
our non object just an actual class of
adoption service but then we have this
concept of a companion object so like I
said things that are static are objects
that are initialized and so when you
create a companion object what you're
doing is saying take this object and
everything that can just run by itself
and just marry that with the class that
holds it so in the end you still end up
executing it the same way where you can
say adoption service that's static adopt
but the biggest difference is that when
you actually try to execute this in
something like Java or in JavaScript you
can't just say adoption service that
static adopt and said you say adoption
service dot companion dot static adopt
so it ends up adding an actual like
static property or object within the
class itself so now that's kind of funky
is anyone have any questions on that
yeah if your class is static so if you
just had an object instead of a class I
don't think objects get sub companion
objects I think it's just classes
abstract classes and I don't think
interface was do either so yeah any
other questions on it cool so let's talk
about what I feel like most people end
up using statics for nowadays and build
extension methods
I see people abused this all the time I
personally do it a lot because it's
super cool to be able to just say like
hot dog dot add up now it looks like a
you know I wrote good code because no
one will see that I just wrote a shitty
extension method I'm not knocking any
with using centrum I really do it all
the time I think they're super cool but
in this case we have to wrap in c-sharp
our extension methods in its own class
usually named with it's our postfix with
extensions and then every method within
that has to be static and if you add
your parameter and you had to this
keyword to the first parameter now we
know the subject of that extension right
so now we know that an adoptable dog
should be able to call adopt and we can
reference the dog anywhere in that
method and call whatever we want on it
Kotlin simplifies this a lot this is
another thing that cotton that I really
do like a lot more than how it's
implemented in c-sharp so same concept
we have an adoption service and it has a
function that calls adopt and it calls
that extension method but what we do to
create an extension function is we take
the type and this is done in global
scope or within any other scope so you
can you can scope your extension methods
which is really cool but you just say
function adoptable pet the the type and
then you define the function right
afterwards so for example if I only
wanted this extension function to be
available within this adoption service I
just lift this bit throw it within that
class and now I can't access it anywhere
else but instead I've gone ahead and
input it at the global level so anyone
that's referencing my package can
execute that we can talk a little bit
more about global scope later on when we
talk about sort of the c-sharp eight
stuff but it's a bit of the side that
gets into like how you can execute
something functionally you don't have to
have a class you just throw functions
wherever you want and import it and then
pipe pipe pipe so some other things that
are common only you can actually add
extension properties I know we've talked
a bit about doing this in c-sharp but
it's it works very similarly to how you
would define a function but instead of
that if I go back having function
adoptable pet adopt we just say Val
adoptable pet name to find the type and
then we have to have explicit getters or
setters so we can't just end it there
just say yep it now it's got a property
called name that's a string but you
can't actually use getters and setters
use some other scope more like a Java
style where you're setting some other
field or something like that you also
have the ability and this is another
thing I don't I don't think I'll ever
find a use case for it but you can add
extensions to your companion object as
well so that like I was saying how in
Java style you have to call doc
companion this is like the same sort of
thing here but you're basically saying
take my companion object of my class and
also give it this extension I guess like
a use case for that would be if you
already have yours to find if someone
else does but you want to give it
another static thing instead of having
like some sort of helper method you can
do that I just haven't really run into
it yet myself so any questions on that
before we get into sort of the cooler
typing sides
and I'm just gonna keep chugging water
cuz my mouth gets so dry cool
so both these languages have some really
cool
typing features not in the sense of a
keyboard typing I mean like an actual
class typing and stuff like that in
c-sharp we were introduced to the
concept of a dynamic type probably the
most hated type of the world has ever
seen
those you hear a C sharp all the time
probably forget that you can even do
this but instead of having a strong type
you just throw dynamic and then the type
checker and compiler just go uh-huh no I
trust you I hope that this pet thing has
an is adopted field but if it doesn't
then the whole thing blows up at runtime
and you also get some very vague errors
and it kind of yells at you for me like
stupid shouldn't use a dynamic type we
also get a dynamic type in Colin but the
funny thing is it doesn't exist in the
JVM so if you're compiling against the
JVM for something like Android or Kate
or you'll never be able to do this you
won't be able to build it'll yell at you
but if you're compiling to native or to
JavaScript you can mostly because
JavaScript everything's a dynamic type
they don't really care it's like saying
and typescript like just type this as
any I don't I don't care what it is but
in the reason why they can't get in the
JVM is because of that backwards
compatibility focus so in order to
support sort of the older legacy
versions of Java that are so sore really
any version of Java it's so tightly
bound to its type system and its
definitions there there's no way they
can build any sort of dynamic or Expando
object or anything like that but if you
are compiling against anything else feel
free to also write this bad code you
also have type inference this is
something that's becoming more popular
in most languages especially new
languages it's something that was
created because we realize as people we
don't we don't need to always say what
it is like we know we can infer that
that P here is an adoptable dog because
I'd know that the the pet exists method
takes in a function that uses an
adoptable pet so I don't have to go and
say adopt a little pet P arrow function
you know ID equals ID but that is where
the influence is happening here
same thing in colonists it's really
similar and there's a few other places
that inference exists in both of these
languages but I figured it was good to
sort
show there's the side-by-sides here so
in on the left side we define an
expression of a thunk of an adoptable
pet to return a bool we just passed that
into the link any method probably
doesn't need to be an expression
honestly I just kind of wasted space
with that and I think about it because I
just been a funk but anyway and then on
the right side and Kotlin we defined a
predicate as the arrow function so this
is the type right this is this is saying
predicate is a function that returns me
a boolean given an adoptable pet and we
also get that sort of any feature if
you've ever tried to write Java lately
you don't get any of this cool like
array management stuff where we
basically get linked in Kotlin but we
won't get into all the sort of library
stuff and then at the top we can say Pet
exists we use an arrow function some
slice and tactical differences there's
actually reasons behind it so we can't
actually create a function as an object
and pass it around in Kotlin simply
because Java is not cool with that so
instead what we do is we basically like
say pet exists is a function and it
takes this function and we're just
executing that function within it that's
something that I think c-sharp just
handles a little bit better but the way
to get around it is pretty clever if
you're passing around a predicate or
something like that you just have to use
the curly braces any questions on any of
the type inference or anything like that
and I'll get into generics cool so
generics one of my favorite things in
sort of the object oriented programming
world but especially in the type
inference world where now we don't have
to build implementations of so many
classes depending on what types we build
we can build like generic stuff that can
do a whole bunch of things and c-sharp
when they implemented generics sort of
became like the leader in terms of like
this is how generics really should be
has all of us love using generics and
c-sharp because we can do things like
say I can take type T but that type T
better be an adoptable pet and because
of that I can now call those methods or
properties like is adopted because I
know that exists on my adoptable pet
other languages like Java is initial
implementation without that it's just it
almost makes generics useless or at
least confusing in order to build
something like in depth they're usable
Kotlin started with generics with that
in mind again just coming from that
background of c-sharp like this works
but I don't like the fact that I have to
say where and put t2 places so and
we define it right here at the top right
we say pet adoption service of type T
and type T better be an adoptable pet of
some kind and then we get the same sort
of autocomplete we get the ability to
compile this in any way we want and use
the is adopted without running into any
errors because we can safely infer the
type so I also want to talk a bit about
tuples this is something that I also see
debated quite a bit in the
object-oriented world because it's kind
of just a shortcut to making to avoid
making like another class just pass in
this type that is these other two types
or three or four end types so for those
of you who don't use tuples or when
c-sharp 7 introduced sums like i don't
care about that it's essentially the
idea of creating a type that contains
multiple other types so in this case we
have this dog and shelter as a type but
those are also two classes below and
then the way that we access each of
those different types within that as we
can say item 1 and now we know that's
the dog versus sorry versus saying item
2 or item 3 and stuff like that but we
can also give them explicit name so I
can say dog and the name of it is pet
and then I can say data dot pet rather
than item 1 but if we don't at least
they give us something to access it you
can also access it with sort of like the
array accessors and stuff like that same
sort of functionality and Kotlin
displayed a little differently with a
little bit of helper tools as well so we
have the idea to apples we have a tuple
type we just basically throw in a bunch
of generics and number of times I think
it's actually limiting it to like 20 or
16 or something like that but I hope you
don't have to run into that but they
also give us two different shortcut
types for tuples so we have pair where
we have two different types which is
what we're using here and then also
triple which is just three different
types so instead of having to say tuple
everywhere and pass it around you know
you get two types and that's how we're
able to get first second and third for
those other types if you go beyond that
you got to use accessors or explicit
naming to pull out those properties so
in this case it's the same thing we're
passing in a pair of type dog and
shelter and we can say data dot first
that is adopted is true questions on any
of the the type stuff I know it's sort
of like it's a very debated
area in in both programming languages
because it's like object-oriented stuff
but they're not so object oriented yeah
yeah you can just like in c-sharp where
you can say like oh this has to be a
class or this has to be a class with
this constructor that takes in these
things or a class with an empty
constructor you can do those same sort
of things in Collin yeah any other
questions cool so my I think favorite
part of modern programming in
asynchronous programming especially
coming from a mobile developer and voice
developer background asynchronous stuff
is extremely important to be able to
take something that in action that
happens on the UI go execute something
in the background while also letting the
user do something but still handle the
result when it comes back is so
invaluable and having to do that before
Kotlin in java was a nightmare and also
just in c-sharp before we were
introduced to async away so let's take a
look at that here c-sharp manages most
of its asynchronous programming with the
concept of async await in tasks so we
have an empty task that means it doesn't
expect a return type now we can say
that's async you can also use async void
but obviously you're gonna get warnings
that are like it should be a task
otherwise you're not really thread safe
and then we can await another
asynchronous task method we can also run
these in other tasks runs we can batch
these asynchronous tasks together and
away all of them a whole bunch of stuff
that makes our lives easier to say like
go do this thing and then like when you
get back and do something else and I'll
just carry on over here if you're doing
it right Collin introduced this concept
in 1.3 and this is what I just recently
updated these slides for this as well
called co-routines
so before co-routines you had to use
other libraries that basically used a
whole bunch of callback methods and
everything else from sort of the
traditional asynchronous programming
similar to more like a promise type
system like javascript has but in this
case now we have Co routines and Co
routines are amazing and they're a very
different approach than other
programming languages take what we have
is the ability to use either a global
scope or a custom defined scope and then
execute co-routines and so the idea is
that we have a global dispatcher or a
custom defined dispatcher that's going
to go execute these tasks and send them
along
but then we can do all sorts of things
with that task while it's executing
including like just waiting for it to
come back executing other co-routines
throwing that on other dispatchers
waiting for a whole bunch to come back
similar functionality that we get in
c-sharp with async await and tasks but
we do get it in sort of like this new
style that almost feels like I can
actually control this without saying
like if I just run tasks that run on an
async oh wait
or a c-sharp task rather I'm gonna end
up risking like exceptions blowing up
and stuff like that where this keeps a
lot of context and you can provide your
own context as well and I'm much more
it's like familiar way so we can look at
like a more real-world example ish
real-world issue obviously this doesn't
do anything where we have this this
background get we have a list of dogs
there and basically want to set that
list of dogs on the background this is
bad code don't actually write stuff like
this is not really thread safe that like
the dogs are gonna be disposed and then
you're gonna lose a whole bunch of stuff
but just bear with me as I go over the
concept so we have a list of dogs and we
want to go get them in the background
while everything else executes below it
so we call it a thought run and a weight
up here up top we have a task that
returns a list of dogs and it's
basically making like a very basic HTTP
GET as a string request that expecting
some JSON and then we just serialize it
with JSON net so what's going to happen
is that we call back round get means
initiate our list of dogs is null we
execute the tasks that run and
everything else below that Jesus keeps
going in that task top run now we go
await that and we set the dogs to the
result like I said this this really
shouldn't actually work because
everything after background get unless
it has something to keep it keep its
context and keep it out of the garbage
collector is going to get booted we can
do the same sort of thing in Kotlin with
co-routines so we have this get
adoptable dogs this get adoptable dogs
it's not executed co-routine it's
basically synchronously going and making
this request other side now don't just
call you or all that read text but I
needed to fit it all in one screen so
it's nice I'm pretty really you should
probably use a better library but anyway
we take that JSON that we get
synchronously waiting for it to read
everything on that thread that it's
executing on and then we do the same
sort of deserialization using google's
json library with that we actually can
execute to get adoptable dogs in back
and so same deal we instantiate a local
variable of list of dogs with no and
then we call the global scope and launch
a new Co routine from the global
dispatcher and set that as get adoptable
dogs so what's going to actually happen
is we execute it instantiate it the
current fires and we just basically
continue on but we can also await a Co
routine and there's a few different ways
you can do that so this is the exact
same code except if we wanted to for
example do like an actual await the the
co-routine to get me the results then we
can call dot join and it basically says
take the test that's running in this Co
routine and bring it back to the throat
where I executed it from or at least in
the thread that I'm calling dot join in
so in this case it's obviously the most
basic example but you can actually take
Co routines that are in like many
different threads and join them into
like other threads in completely
different areas and sort of give it new
contexts and stuff like that which i
think is pretty wild and I don't think
it's something you can do very easily in
c-sharp so from there we can talk about
tooling but if you have any questions
about any of the asynchronous stuff let
me know cool
so in c-sharp we have some of the best
developer tools I think you guys if you
have to go and write JavaScript code or
something and come back to C sharp
you're like oh my god yes I can actually
like do things quickly and just like
control period and tab around and do
everything I want the way I want and
everything's fast at least that's how I
normally feel we have things like Visual
Studio which is now have even even newer
focus in terms of like building better
developer tools we have AI and our
intellisense we have things that predict
the way that we personally use the
editor to make it easier to like hey I
know you name parameters like this so
let me just auto suggest that you can
just tap your way through it and it's
like you're not even writing code
anymore
we have vias coat the slimmed down
version you can saw some c-sharp plugins
and and carry on the way you would
expect and then we can also now write it
on the Mac outside of the Visual Studio
line of tools there's also been this
sort of new player named rider this is
from JetBrains if you haven't used it
before it's incredible how many of you
guys use resharper at all in your visual
studio yeah that'd be a lot imagine just
resharper has an IDE with like
everything else IntelliJ has been
writing the entire time
the difference is that it's not free
because it's all part of the the
JetBrains package I personally love
Ryder a lot I mostly use Visual Studio
just for consistency sake between like
my Mac and my Windows machine but writer
does actually run on all platforms
including Linux Mac and Windows and it's
the exact same interface like you'd
expect where if you've used Visual
Studio for Mac it's more Maki it's a
little different you sort of got to get
used to setting things up a little
differently or just like force yourself
into using the command key as a control
key and like try to keep the same
shortcuts which I personally just can't
execute well on the cotton side we have
a similar set of awesome tools so we
have IntelliJ the og of Java
environments that were actually decent
separate from Eclipse which if you if
you still have to use eclipse I'm really
sorry it hasn't gotten much better
IntelliJ just like Rider or using
resharper you're gonna get the same feel
and we have Android studio for Android
development this is basically Google
partnering with JEP rating that's saying
like hey I like what you guys are doing
let us just put a whole bunch of Android
stuff on top of that but it's really the
same sort of actual intellisense same
sort of code management with a whole
bunch of stuff to like Auto generate
some Android stuff but in terms of
Kotlin support IntelliJ and Android
studio operate in the exact same way you
can do that whole like copy Java over to
Kotlin like I mentioned and then eclipse
they've built a plugin for you so you
can still suffer it with Kotlin so
tooling aside anyone have any questions
I'm not going to be able to have time to
do like any demos of the IDE s or
anything like that so if you have
questions about like how that sort of
stuff works right good time to ask her
save it for the end and then after that
I'll talk about the c-sharp eight stuff
which you've probably heard a whole
bunch of times already cool all right so
let's dig into the stuff in c-sharp
eight and I sort of think of this and
it's four major features and also how
this features can also be reflected in
common it's stuff that colin has
actually had for quite a while so we
looked at knowable reference types in
Kotlin and this is actually a behavior
you can't turn off
we're in c-sharp eight it's something
you'll be able to explicitly add and we
get the difference between now our
string has a question mark next to it to
denote it as a knowable reference type
we have that same sort of like automatic
behavior and type checking and
everything else it says hey you try to
access something that's knowable you
either need to propagate it with null or
you need to dangerously set it with a
bang so the biggest difference is you
you'll probably still notice is that on
the c-sharp side for knowable types we
still won't have to explicitly and
instantiate it as null because the
default of a noble types no C sharp
smart enough to do that and so I
actually really prefer the way C sharp
does it however if we do take off one of
those question marks for something like
name we do have to instantiate that with
a name in the C sharp side on the right
side of the equation the next one is
ranges which I I don't know if I've
actually had like a real need for it but
it's sort of like a neat thing to have
that other languages have also had for a
while so it's in this case I'm showing
like the most basic example of a range
where I'm defining a range as 1 to 4 in
terms of positioning so instead of
looping over every dog that's sent down
to me I'm saying give me from position 1
to position 4 and then also write their
names in the console but obviously I'm
not tight like checking like others
listed dogs not no one does it also like
have at least four available I don't
care about that right now Colin is the
same thing this is another thing we're C
sharp when they implement I was like how
this is a nice little shortcut to add so
on the right side in in Kotlin you'll
notice that we have the ability to
assign a range as a variable you can
also do that in c-sharp or range as a
type and we can pass it around but I did
want to show off where C sharp is a
little bit more clever where on the
right side we don't have that access or
with a range so we can't just take a
list and say give me one to four like we
can in c-sharp but we can still define
as a type pass it around and do all that
but instead we just call like the sub
list and it's still clean but I think
this is like the first time the c-sharp
side got to like fewer lines of code
also because we just have the obnoxious
same line brackets which I still
internally debate so often we also were
introduced to default interface
implementations so I know some of you
guys probably already went to all the
c-sharp eight talks and I think one of
them at least talked about this quite a
bit but if you remember our original
interface conversation with comparing it
and c-sharp Scotland left side was only
those two definitions in the contract
rather than
actual implementation this time around
these look a lot more similar where we
actually are able to implement adopt
dogs it has to be explicitly public in I
adoption service where we sort of get
the next default public comment right
other than that it's still basically the
same other other than little syntactical
things we now have the same capability
of default interface implementations
that we've had in column for the whole
time and Collins just had it because
Java has had default interface
implementations for like ever probably
the only thing Java had over C sharp
which is also even just the beta extract
class was make an interface and just
have interfaces that I just don't
actually use as an interface and I don't
know I like it I'll probably use it this
one is my favorite and it's something I
feel like people haven't really talked
about enough people are all about the
noble reference type and how your codes
gonna be cleaner and it's gonna be safer
throw away the no reference exception or
the null pointer exception in the Kotlin
and java world but this one I feel like
I could I can like actually really use
and I'll try to sort of like visualize
what I thought about when I when I
started putting together this slide
earlier today I'll go through the code
first so we have this concept of an i
async enumerable and this is what it's
giving us the ability to stream things
from that enumerable so in that method
we're returning and I sync enumerable of
type string given a list of dogs and
we're looping over those dogs and saying
pause for a bit then yield the return of
that name of the dog so if I mean I
personally didn't use yield a whole lot
back when I was writing a bunch of
c-sharp seven but it's basically saying
I'm building an enumerable throw this
one in there right so every time we hit
this we're actually adding something to
that enumerable and down below when
we're running it we can just loop over
that just like we would with any sort of
for each loop but instead this is going
to hit that console dot write line every
200 milliseconds with that name so it
sounds like why would I use I just like
batch load stuff and I don't really care
but the way I sort of thought about it
from like a mobile perspective is a lot
of the way the paradigm works right now
is you're loading a list of data you're
gonna go grab like a chunk of like 10
things load it into a list and carry on
well this sort of gives us the ability
to like a synchronous load one thing at
a time especially if you're interfacing
with something like an
API that doesn't have like a bulk with
pagination capabilities in the API to
say like skip this Manning take this
many and said I can just go like give me
the one by this ID then this idea then
this ID and instead of just saying task
delay and return the name I can say go
make an HTTP request make that async go
give me the result of that and then pipe
that back down and then loop over that
so I don't know I thought it was really
cool and I feel like not enough people
are talking about it this is something
where again we've got way more lines of
code and Kotlin to do it but it's
possible and this is in some of the
experimental things of columns so while
we're talking about the feature of C
sharp with C sharp 8 this is actually
sort of like the future of Kotlin which
i think is planned to be fully released
in one point-four so let me just break
this down for you from from the top down
we have a an async get name which is an
async Metheny actually could see the
async keyword which we're getting a
little bit into sort of the new KO
routine stuff don't get into too much
detail but the same thing we're just
getting the name of the dog delay it
then return it then we have the actual
get of all the names right so we have
the ability to taken a list of dogs go
over returning is actually a list of
deferred of string a noble string so
that deferred type is what allows us to
actually await the individual result of
it so what we're doing is calling an
array mapper map to get the async name
then in the actual running block which
again is fired in a KO routine we're
able to say give me the names and then
loop over them and await the individual
result of it so getting the async names
gives me the whole list of the deferred
and it's just going to continue to run
that and then I'm going to await the
result of each individual piece which is
pretty cool but it's obviously a little
bit more involved and we're actually
doing it was sort of like the more
functional style where we're defining it
at the co-routine scope rather than
doing it in an object but I thought it
was a pretty cool example any questions
about sort of like those really really
new really cool c-sharp 8 features or
how you can actually implement the same
sort of thing in Collin
so in this case it's going to execute it
one at a time
so in this async name all we're saying
is that we're mapping the list of dogs
to basically the list of this method
this async function in the code routine
so this is an entire function and we're
actually mapping the dogs to that list
of that function and then we're able to
await it one at a time so you can think
of like this this list of deferred
string is like a list of a function that
returns me a string asynchronously and
so then we're able to loop over that
list just like we would any other and
then we just say dot await and we'll
wait for the individual result of each
one in the list any questions cool I
think this is like the last major
section but talking about now the future
of Kotlin there's a lot going on it's
open source so it's not just JetBrains
working on it although they have a
dedicated team of some of the best
developers in the world designing this
language it's also open source and
allowing people to actually make poor
request to the compilers so the
JavaScript compiler I believe actually
came from an initial concept from an
open source community member so if
you're interested in actually getting
involved in a community that's like very
open to the concept of people hopping in
which also has great documentation sort
of the best place to be but let's talk
about them one by one some more code
routine stuff it's it's brand new like
1.3 just released that's when they were
finally like co-routines are ready but
like I just said with that sort of
streaming asynchronously stuff and that
deferred type and being able to dock oh
wait that that's still experimental I
wouldn't be using that in production so
that sort of stuff is going to continue
to be developed to continue to be tested
against all the different platforms also
the native compiler it's currently in
beta which is also the 1.3 release
pushed it to beta they're basically just
trying to get it ready for for a
production environment and then
continued IDE enhancements this is
mostly in regards to the multi-platform
stuff so if you've ever run dotnet with
multi-platform so something like is
Ameren or even just like talking to a
SPI web app and then like a console app
and you're abstracting your code into
like different projects that it then
references
kahlan's trying to do more of this
because it has to use a different
compile
for each of those different platforms so
being able to support code that's shared
between JavaScript and Java and Native
and iOS with all of its extra tooling
they want to be able to build it into
the tooling a bit better to handle that
so this is also in preview right now
they're trying to push people to do it a
bit more
same thing with c-sharp if you're
already writing c-sharp apps and you
ready have a whole bunch of business
logic just you know throw throw a mobile
app on it and and run with it now
they're trying to promote that sort of
behavior as well so that's that's it
I'll get it in the into the summary but
what I hope you can take away from this
is that both these languages are super
cool and you can take the knowledge of
the style that you develop in c-sharp
and apply it to places where it can't
support it right now build stuff on the
JVM if you're in consulting and someone
comes even like oh yeah we got this
legacy Java system and I need you to
come in and help us work on and you're
like I'm a dotnet div that kind of sucks
it doesn't have to suck any more
kontin's pretty cool or if you just hate
javascript so much and you don't feel
like touching typescript which is my
other I'd put it over here with my like
third favorite language you can also
write Cottle in there as well and share
that across your different platforms so
I also want to emphasize that we like
barely barely scratch the surface with
this language in the platform's we
didn't really talk about anything about
the functional side because we're
comparing it to c-sharp I definitely
encourage people to look into that a bit
more we didn't talk about any real
design patterns other than here's
object-oriented programming we're going
to talk about how you can implement
things like dependency injection proper
inversion of control with other
practices we didn't get into much of the
actual deeper language features we
talked about the basics and we talked
about co-routines which is probably
about as far as we could go we also
didn't talk about any of the cool
tooling that the cotton team is built
like couture and how that's actually
implemented and why it's so much better
and faster than spring and arguably in
certain cases than dotnet core or anko
which is their whole other suite of
tools that can do just about anything
for you including like data syncing
between your code routines and stuff
like that we can get into how to build
things with native or with JavaScript or
into all the other cool Android tools so
I definitely encourage you to sort of do
that research if you if you've found
interest in the language itself it's
definitely worth seeing what you can
really do with it because it's pretty
crazy so I have some resources here that
that's the actual compiler set for cots
spec and compiler and everything else
open source by JetBrains there is also a
Colin organization which has like the
extra toolings like Kate or and anko and
stuff like that all the examples that
you saw in the slides are also available
on my github including what my original
talk was which was also included a basic
Android app with Kotlin to a xamarin
Android app that's also up there we just
don't have time to continue to go over
the sort of basics I wanted to introduce
the c-sharp eight concepts because I
felt that was more interesting also
check out my plural site course on it if
you're interested in doing Kotlin in an
actual implementation I have this
building Android apps with Kotlin
getting started it's it's interesting we
go through the process of building a
real-world app from scratch without any
assumption of Kotlin knowledge at all so
we we do things like execute request to
a third party API and then actually sync
that down to a local database handle
navigation in a more complex app between
different types and sort of the
different layouts and structures you can
use in Android and then like I said at
the beginning check out my blog series
on this and all my other Kotlin and
c-sharp stuff and then I'll put these
slides up on Twitter at the end so be
sure to follow me swab underscore pirate
there and thank you it's left to anyone
does have questions or anything or just
wants to talk